and it's gonna be hot again today huh
sherry yeah I think the a little sibling
there running around like we'd all like
to uh-huh no pants all do that today
you've got to wear pants everybody or a
skirt or shorts or something to stay
cool we've got dry gusty winds those
will stay with us thunderstorms again
around the four corners today with that
monsoon moisture we won't have to worry
about those in Southern Nevada but we do
have to worry about a lot of heat one
teens again for the valley 90s up in the
mountains 40 plus mile an hour winds
with wind advisories today 11:00 a.m. to
8:00 p.m. for the lake and we're also
looking at red flag warnings that's hot
dry windy conditions 111 for Las Vegas
near 110 for Barstow look at the one
teens Laughlin all the way down to Yuma
today and over into Phoenix so hot dry
conditions and the winds will stay with
us breezy tonight back to windy tomorrow
and we get a slight break in the heat
108 Tuesday down to 107 for the rest of
the week stay hydrated please take care
of the pets the little ones in the
elderly they don't do so well in this
extreme heat in fact a lot of missed Oh
Nate
[Music]